- This actually might not
be as hard as I thought,
but then again, with the last cheesecake;
I got cocky, and then I made seven.
(upbeat music)
Hi, I'm Kiano, I'm a
Tasty Producer and today
I'm gonna be testing a
four flavor cheesecake.
It's all gonna be made in one pan.
And, I want to find out if it's possible.
And if it works, I'll
make a video out of it.
How do I keep the flavors
from not mixing together?
So my first thought is
to use Graham Crackers,
which, these are all broken.
Step one, make sure your
Graham Crackers aren't broken,
'cause nothing will work.
I think, if I wrap these in foil;
I can get it to be a bit sturdier.
Look at this! I can do a wedge!
So this is my pan.
So the goal is to make sure that chocolate
and lemon don't touch.
Caramel and raspberry can go either way
'cause it doesn't really matter.
There.
Okay.
This is where it gets stressful.
Need to add gelatin to my
cream, and whisk it in there.
Slowly pour hot gelatin
cream into the cream cheese.
That is a lot of very liquidy batter.
The batter needs to be thick to hold it
and right now it's really thin.
You know what, it'll be fine.
I'm just gonna divide it
into four equal parts.
So two and a quarter into each bowl.
Uh-oh, did I do my math wrong?
Why does it feel like
there's nothing left?
This is correct math, I'm so sure of it.
I mean, it doesn't have
to be perfect today.
I just want to find out if it works.
So I'm gonna put all
of these in the fridge,
and then it'll become
cold, and if I whip it,
it should be thick; and
then it won't be ruined.
Oh, it's working!
It is sturdy, look at that.
Chocolate is nice and melty.
I think that's a good amount of chocolate.
It's like a, it's brown.
Let's go with a tablespoon of lemon curd.
All right, that should
be all right for now.
I'm just gonna dollop this,
I don't want it to be perfect,
I just, or like, pink.
It's probably already too much.
I think I'm at that point
where, oh, holy bejeeze,
I need to make a crust.
Touch of sugar, and some butter,
press it down really tight.
Scrape, oh geez, this is getting messy.
I think I need a new course of action.
This actually might work,
they're kind of standing up.
Let's see if they're sturdy
enough to put batter into.
So far, so good.
Okay, so there's promise with this one.
Oh God, this is not gonna be a pretty one,
but, lessons learned.
I think a lot of progress
has been made today.
From the first batch I realized
I made too much batter.
So, I'm gonna try another
batter reduced by a third.
This is already so much
better than the first batter.
I'm just gonna divide it using my eyes.
Is that smart?
Smooth sailing, this is so much easier.
Last time we had to like,
measure and do math.
I'm just gonna pour in the
butter, zip, and shake.
Before it was just like all
loose, and now it's able
to like crunch together and
compact; which is what you want.
For all those little bits to become one.
The double crust is
also another reason why
I reduced the batter.
Normally, crust is like
a great way to have
a foundation for your chesecake.
This is working, this is properly working.
This is a bit thinner than my last batter.
It's like I don't think it's
as firm as the other ones.
There's definitely not
enough of this batter,
because all the other cakes took it all.
I mean it's working, it's not pretty.
So I really want to
practice making it look good
'cause I have chocolate hazelnut candy,
and I have the exact number.
So next layer is the lemon curd
and I'm just gonna spread.
I was gonna go for the
whole chocolate turtle vibe.
Caramel turtle, turtle?
Okay, looks like there's
cockroaches on the cheesecake.
Raspberry time, swirl around.
This is hideous right now.
It was almost perfect.
That looks weird, but you know, it's fine
'cause I'm not gonna be using them.
I think it's very safe to
say that this cheesecake has
come a long way from the
first one to the second one.
I think Day Three will be the one.
I feel good about Day Three.
Day Three is like not as scary
'cause I know what I'm doing finally.
So to do that, I'm doing two cups instead
of three cups of heavy whipping cream.
And hope that there'll be no waste.
Hopefully not too little.
Is it too little?
Oh this one's too low too.
Of course that's one that has plenty.
This batter I messed up
because there's too little.
So they need to all be level.
I'm kind of over it for today.
I thought today would be done
and nothing would go wrong.
So I'm just gonna get ready for Day Four.
Today I can finally cut the cake.
Right now I need to figure out
how to get it out of the pan.
I saw on the interweb that
you could use a blow torch
to help soften up the edges.
Definitely feels less cold around the edge
so I think I'm gonna
try using the knife now.
Uh-oh, I might have blow
torched too much 'cause
I can feel my edges being a little melty.
Uh-oh, I feel like I might
have melted it too much.
Oh wait, oh my god, it's just
like the crust down there.
Okay, I'm gonna put it on a cake plate.
Do you wanna put the whole thing
in the freezer for a couple minutes.
All right, it's time
for the moment of truth.
It's coming off.
(applauding)
It's off, it looks nice from the top.
There's something up
with this caramel one.
'Cause everything else
seems so much more firm.
Gravity does not agree with that one.
Maybe it's 'cause the caramel sauce brand
is like really thin
compared to everything else.
I don't want to make another cheesecake,
but, something needs to be changed.
And I'm gonna have to make a new batter.
Hopefully only one more.
Today is not the day.
I think it's Day Five, maybe Day 12,
but I finally have solved
the caramel problem.
So caramel itself has so much water in it,
and that's why the
cheesecake wouldn't set.
So I'm gonna use Dulce
de leche which is a lot
thicker than caramel and
hopefully will hold together.
It's like a lot thicker
and lot more golden.
What have I learned?
Oh boy, I have learned
that you should not give up
on anything 'cause every
little curve was a easy fix.
You just took a little bit of
breathing time to sort out.
It's ready, I'm gonna
go pop it in the fridge
and four hours later,
we'll have a beautiful,
perfect, four flavor cheesecake.
(triumphant music)
I don't have words to describe
how excited I am right now.
Phew!
Oh yeah.
That is what I'm talking about.
Look at that!
That is one solid, yet
creamy, piece of cheesecake.
The past month I have been
developing this very crazy
but very delicious recipe
for four flavored cheesecake
in one pan and finally it is done.
And I am happy, it is
beautiful, people like it,
and hopefully our audience likes it too.
Can I go home now?
(laughing)
(classical music)